When You Reach this point where you're
the richest person in the world the
reality of life kind of Fades away and
you get into this very strange bubble
and he was never the easiest person to
give critical feedback to that was sort
of like a life and death proposition for
the rank and file employees at the
company you know I've texted them when
he was doing crazy things on Twitter
like you know that's just too far don't
do that so I mean he will change his
mind if enough people go at it but I
think he's pretty much gonna do what
he's gonna do man I mean that is elon's
bonus operandi and he believes some of
these things on like a religious level
you know his life for the last 20 25
years has been to set up this human
Colony on Mars and he sees that as like
an existential risk and sort of the
highest priority somebody could chase
after and he absolutely believes that in
his heart like none of this has anything
to do with making money or anything like
that